casini on arrive toujours pas enfin je
ne comprends pas il m'a donné
rendez-vous maintenant ici pour répéter
la dent mais ne ta passion de parle je
lis au
je crois que je l'aperçois sur le chemin
du port mes amis ça arrive ratant des
eaux non là je n'en peux plus je suis
épuisée que tu arrives dit si tu ne vas
pas pouvoir danser dans cet état tu as
cru casimir on dirait ça c'est très bien
de vouloir être à leurs bras mais non je
n'ai pas couru le même pour un grand
fidèle au rendez-vous le jury il a fallu
que j'aille chercher les disques qu'ils
avaient prêté au capitaine du port eh
bien eh bien eh bien il n'était pas au
port alors je suis allé chez lui et il
habite au cinquième étage enfin il a
l'air sincère apave a paru hors de ce
monstre ah oui le gardien m'a justement
dit vous n'avez qu'à après l'ascenseur
alors j'ai appelé l'instance harassant
et bien il n'est pas venu je fais
remonter à pied à chaque étage je criais
à s'en sort quand j'ai dû payer de
confort il s'attache et il a le coeur
gros bêta appelé l'ascenseur ça veut
dire à cuillé sur le bouton d'appel mais
oui quasi mais c'est un duo qui se
trouve près de la porte alors on appuie
dessus ça produit un contact électrique
l'ascenseur se met en marche et viet
rejoindra les tâches du trouve et bien
le gardien avec un expliqué pour sa part
enfin en tout cas je les 10 kg nous
allons pouvoir bon en fait je
ne voit-on pas chez moi chercher le mien
un camping ou d'enfants une autre fois
pas si vite j'ai justement apporter avec
moi tourne-disque à piles pour mieux
apprendre l'anglais on vous le prêter
aussi gentil françois ça s'appelle un
tourne-disque un mange disque à face et
amusant car non oui on appelle ça un
ange 10 passes comme pour le faire
fonctionner on introduit le disque dense
ex-anpe et tu vois cette france
ressemble à une grosse bouche ça vous
ouais l'installer sur le bord des jeux
10ème mon disque d'or bon je vous laisse
tous les deux dans ces rien attend
françois je viens avec toi et casimir
j'ai oublié mes chaussures de danse
j'arrive tout de suite d'accord
dépêche-toi julie
fois ci c'est joli en mange disque à
quel drôle de no1 en efforts on dirait
une bourse
elle est grande mais quand même un peu
plus petite la mirena et lui il peut
manger toute la journée mais s'il peut
manger des disques à moi qui ai une
bouche plus grand que lui je pourrais
peut-être en faire autant essayons
je vois la casinière tu m'as pas trop
attendu j'espère non non je lis pas du
tout
qu'est ce que tu dis
rien rien d'un chanteur d'un rabbin les
boulevards taschereau
moi bien sûr c'est qu'une chanson
indienne bon en place tu mets la musique
d'accord
je ne comprends pas s'est appuyé sur le
bouton il ne marche pas mais c'est
encore
là là là ça y est ça marche qu'est ce
qui arrive là je ne sais pas moi
il n'y a pas de disque à l'intérieur
bordeaux dit assure pourtant
tu l'as bien glisser là comme ça mais
bien sûr
pis s de chantonnay comme ça tu tues
m'agace n'est pas tombé
je lis je crois avoir une solution
j'aimerais bien écoutez je pense que
france aura nous a traité un mange
disque gourmands
oui là il a mangé lots distincts
[Musique]
quand reviendra
nous quitter
ton
[Musique]
de prendre
on a tout le temps
[Musique]
et terra mair
le temps
[Musique]
et d
tous les
[Musique]
c'est les planchers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
on les ferme et pourtant
année
[Musique]
non non nous ferons part nous ne nous
ferons pas
[Musique]
puis nous ferons automne
pensant
[Musique]
échanges
ignoble
elle tombait
les meilleurs délais pour qu'on la fait
plus de passes
moi et mon ami
nos clients enfin don à nous qu'ils
n'auront pas
[Musique]
nez rouge paul desbiens
l'appui
[Musique]
dans
la plaie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais
mais dont les fleurs et les fruits
de par moi et mon ami thomas donne nos
guitares opa d'un anneau qui trompe pas
je crois qu'en dit monsieur martin je
m'en donnait pas civile
[Rires]
bon j'espère que vous n'aurez plus
d'ennuis je suis allez vous chercher mon
petit magnétophone et la musique de
votre danse et dessus julie dunac
appuyer sur ce bouton c'est la sim et ça
marche tout seul tiens bon dans ses
biens à l'intérieur
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
oh
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
tu as très bien dans l'oeuf et casimir
dit moi je retourne à mon coeur cas
parce que j'ai beaucoup de travail à
tout à l'heure moi je vais rendre le
magnétophone à françois
comment est ce que ça peut bien
fonctionner cet engin là
je restais un petit coup d'oeil
discrètement
beaucoup alors que je suis maladroit du
bon il faut que je remette ça sans que
personne ne voie rien mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça on dirait des spaghettis ça
alors personne ne dit jamais rien là moi
voyons voir
mais ils sont pas mauvais du tout être
des spaghettis au caramel ça alors c'est
délicieux
moyon
[Musique]
c'est vraiment
par contre on annonce à sa charge suis
pas content du tout non je vous prête
mon mon magnétophone vous perdez la
bande magnétique avons juste avait prêté
mon tour de 10 ch vous avez perdu le
disque non non non c'est pas content du
tout je suis pas content du tout non je
t'assure que je n'y suis pour rien enfin
la rectorie mire c'est un fou de
kazimiya casimir je prête à fumer à
faire j'ai terminé encore plus
d'attention le délicieux ta question
quand on y chante que j'avais préparé
extrait pour lui des spaghettis on est
chauds parfaitement monsieur fabien ça
m'est complètement égal mademoiselle
tard j'en ai mangé des biens meilleurs
j'aime manger des spaghettis au caramel
a dit moin té in here qui plaisait
donner
enfin
la wii
il a vraiment du beau shine on regarde
casimir garde
[Musique]
cas julien dubois
casimir